you've said several times that you feel  like people in the black community are  hypocrites because they say to you black  people aren't Republicans you know what  are you doing you're being used or you  know you're being played with by the  Republican Party what do you think when  you say that because that it that's  something I've heard about you as well  well I've heard it too and it's it's  absurd first they need to do their  homework because there are a lot of  black Republicans and I feel completely  safe safer among Republicans than any  other party really and they represent  everything that I stand for and  everything and I always stand stood for  but I just didn't know it you are on the  verge at one point of having an abortion  and you said and I didn't that's right  God spoke to me and God told me keep  your son and I did and he saved my life  my son saved my life  had I not had my son I would probably be  dead right now  I know I would